tellement de demandes un truc qui les
tuyaux qui sortaient de partout et
j'étais des visages et je me suis dit
non ça c'est pas moi c'est pas possible
[Musique]
je pensais pas que c'était si grave que
ça malgré l'excitation du mythe scène
[Musique]
et
donc on a conclu que la meilleure
technique pour vous reconstruire sa
serait de mettre une épithète lépi thèse
c'est quoi c'est une prothèse qui va
imiter la région mon camp
[Musique]
pierre un sourcil un oeil pour pouvoir
vous balader dans la rue
prendre le train le métro sans que les
gens se retourner sans avoir besoin de
mettre un pansement comme vous le faites
actuellement je vous fais confiance
[Musique]
durand règle j'aperçois des trucs comme
des veines à l'intérieur dans le moindre
détail tout effet les y aller a
l'impression on a l'impression qu'ils
aillent et humidifier la langue
tout y est je travaille sur l'ouverture
beloeil pour comprendre ne sera guère le
plus naturel possible
[Musique]
mon avis montre encore un peu le volume
par ici au niveau de la joue super 8
[Musique]
je suis content de ce que je vois déjà
et puis pour les petits détails comme le
sourcil et les petits grains de beauté
on les fera à la fin par dessus pour
donner un peu de relief
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant
vraiment
[Musique]
bon je vais te mettre la prothèse pour
vérifier on y va allez zou
[Musique]
ce n'est assez facilement c'est bien ça
vous mêmes faits et repris la marque
dacia triste elle prend vraiment sa
position et elle colle très facilement
dans un bon truc
théo au dessus de ce que je juge je
m'attendais fait vraiment c'est énorme
[Musique]
la cipa vrai t'as vu ses revenus si tu
veux toucher très passante la dogimont
100 places et même ce sens que ça va
t'on simple arty je collectais je
connaissais tous nous en fait
oh tu vois
[Musique]